blender brain we maybe tokens but we're
damn good-looking ones you think it
would dishonor dr. King's memory if I
went to sit in the back of the bus so
we'd need to talk about how iconic Jody
Landon is 20 years ago
dharia came to MTV the show focuses on
the shade icon herself daria
morgendorffer and our family and
schoolmates at Lawndale high this looks
well-balanced damage we've got four
mouths to feed
food costs money I knew it the show was
really ahead of its time it touched on
feminism social class and thanks to one
of the show's few characters of color
Jody
race as well homegirl literally ran
londo high school valedictorian of her
graduating class overall no hi I'm
president of the French club vice
president of student council editor of
yearbook ends I'm also on the tennis
team she had the black boyfriend box
braids poppin unapologetic attitude she
carries herself with so much class and
dignity
someday I'd like to own my own business
maybe a consulting firm geared toward
minority startups truly was someone that
I wanted to be best friends with but she
was also very vocal about what it means
to be under this gaze of being the
perfect minority in the token black
girls at home I'm Jody I can see or do
whatever feels right but at school and
the queen of the Negros the perfect
african-american teen the role model for
all of the other african-american teens
at Lawndale oops
where's they go to its credit the show
positioned Jodie to be the biggest
critic of the show's overwhelming
whiteness isn't it great how they keep
electing us homecoming king and queen
every year yes
it's such a generous and enlightening
gesture it completely makes up for the
town's utter lack of diversity in my
mind and we're playing into it damn
college applications this is so
humiliating Jodie was woke before I
won't even know what what was why play
into this stupid charade any more than
we have to
[Applause]
what happened
Oh what the hell we may be tokens but
we're damn good-looking ones not only
we're Jody and her boyfriend Mack
Mackenzie some of the few characters of
color but they were also the only
secondary characters to have a
three-dimensional storyline independent
from the show's white lead in the show's
film length finale is it College yet
Jody and her parents debate over which
college Jody was point to go to would it
be the elitist Ivy League school press
war or their historically black college
Turner I want to go to Turner at least
for a year or two you want to go to
college to relax relax socially stop
being the black kid and just be a kid
I'm tired of being in the extreme
minority and I don't want to go to a
place where people might think I got in
just because I'm african-american now in
the end
Jody chooses to go to Turner with her
parents support my parents said if I was
so upset about crestmore that I'd
applied to Turner behind their backs
they had to respect my feelings they
told me I'd earned the right to be
treated like an adult as we look back on
the 20 year anniversary of Daria it's
time that we give Jody Landon the
respect and credit that she deserves her
poise and dignity personify what it
means to be black girl magic
[Music]